hey what what do you think attributes to
your
mentality being so young like was it
something growing up was it your family
because like i think maybe seeing mama
because it's not like i had i didn't
have no father figure like so i think
maybe just seeing my mom work 24 7 like
all [ __ ] day just seeing how hard she
worked made me want to be like yo
i wanna i wanna be a hard worker too
you feel me but i'm not about to do no
regular [ __ ] yeah i just think like
there's not a lot of people that are
your age that think the way you think
it's very rare i don't know what it is
maybe you know what it what it might be
too just seeing like all these other
artists like the few that are like me
and just hearing them talking that's
just motivating so you know like we got
a big we got a big influence on on all
the youth who motivated you uh man
hearing nipsy talk
like hearing nipsey i used to watch all
his interviews and just hearing him
talking
you could just tell like how different
someone is yep he's wired different man
yeah you can see like where their head
is that and it's crazy yeah i think
nipsey influenced so many people hell
yeah you know think of white but why
geez doing you know why he's doing the
weed thing he's doing the he's got his
shoes his clothing line you know i mean
exactly exactly
i think like nipsey's influence will
just live forever from this point
because you're gonna influence somebody
exactly you know what i mean
and so on and so forth so